Hopefully, your analytics dashboard
is now showing some activity in
the shopping behavior and
checkout behavior dashboards.
But so far, the checkout
process has been very simple.
The steps are, view product, add to
cart, start checkout and purchase.
But there are some steps missing.
Where do we send the tasty dinner?
And what are the payment details?
The checkout process itself
is a multi step process.
You have to get the shipping address,
get payment address,
get payment details,
confirm the details, review order,
and then finally, do the purchase.
So here's an example of a checkout
process with a bunch of steps.
Start the checkout.
Get the customer info.
Get the billing info.
Let the customer review the cart.
Confirm the checkout.
And there would be one more step
which is to complete the purchase.
There are two things you have to do to
display the checkout steps in analytics.
You have to update your code to include
the step number when your
app sends a check out hit.
And then the admin console,
you can add funnel sections for
the checkout process.
This part's actually optional but
if you don't name the check out
steps then they appear as step one,
step two, step three and so
on which is not very helpful.
So here's an example where we have
step one, step two, step three,
step four and we don't know what's
going on at each of these steps.
It's really very easy to add
nice labels for these steps.
So here's how to set a heading for
the steps.
You go to the admin console,
choose Ecommerce settings down here for
the view, and
then just add some funnel steps.
So you add the steps that you'll be
tracking, and give them relevant names.
And don't forget to press
submit when you're done.
Sometimes the submit button scrolls
off the bottom of the screen and
it's easy to forget it.
Then, take a look at
the Checkout report.
So go to Reporting >
Ecommerce Shopping Analysis.
And checkout behavior and then you'll
see the steps with the new labels.
It's your turn now to add the checkout
step to analytics account.
Go to Ecommerce.
And set up the funnel steps, right here.
Then go back to the reporting tab to
see the steps in the checkout
behavior analysis screen.
Check the boxes here when you've
added the checkout steps.
We'll be adding the code next.